fresh you know I know where you live but
you're like so good you're never gonna
grow a penis my name is Michelle I'm 33
and I am a si a dual security I wanted
to take the role as a security guard and
just flip it I wanted to bring a little
bit of style a little bit of sass and
that's what I did
great why is your face away seriously on
bone serious
hey smartphone again being female
security people warm to me because I
look different and I'm like here come on
it's 2018 time for a change
[Music]
my name is Eli I'm 34 years old and I'm
a bartender I like the freedom of
skateboarding to work it's just a nice
relaxing thing to get you into the start
of a shift the thing that I enjoy most
working on the bar is he gets have a bit
of a chat with people give him a bit of
cheap now and again show off a little
bit in my workplace me being transgender
has helped to create an open dialogue
just by virtue the fact that people know
that I'm open to talking about it the
reactions from my co-workers are
generally quite respectful they were
happy for me to lead the way with
explaining things one of the guys I
worked with he is like it's amazing I've
got so many questions for you I went oh
my god aren't you like so good you're
never gonna grow a penis though then
later on in the night again he sort of
turned round he won't tell you what if I
die you can have mine as the toilet
attendant I'm happy because the space is
free for everybody people lose me as
precious everybody lost precious people
come to the club because of precious
music and people is perfect
oh thank you very much darling
it's a nice thing on a shift to see a
familiar face thank you for being a big
fun I don't mind people telling me that
you're was I think me being transgender
gives me that extra dimension where I
can have a deeper insight into some of
the things that people are struggling
with
did you love bringing ID you're sure you
know I'm enough to give you lord
caitanya working a custom service gave
me the skills to speak to people laugh
with people have Bantle people and make
myself approachable so I can defuse the
situation rather than escalate it
you lot may enter I know people Suede's
when they dance and I know they love to
freshen up that's why I put spare him
deodorants comb brush everything they
will need everybody wants to look good
everybody wants to smell nice fresh you
know when you come inside dance drink
shall roll around as long as it's not
affecting anybody else then it's all
good the people that are here to
actually have a good time feel safe my
favorite part of the night is and I'm at
the door everyone smiling turning up and
then I can hear little booth booth - and
I'm like oh that's my
oh yeah I enjoy working on those is a
1-up or colas robbery people love
lollipop
people love strawberry the rudiments
song I don't want to say dear Rudy's in
a club is no route in agenda neutral
space I think nice song for everybody
fresh you know for everybody my dear
friends pure guys approaching the bar
and you wanted to us something about
transgender people we all want to know
things about each other like as long as
you respect for it's okay to ask hi you
guys alright yeah you are here to create
an environment where you're free to be
yourselves and that's why I love my job
if I can just want you to just walk that
way for me please yeah yeah okay thank
you so much thank you have a good
evening bye bye